you chose two very special songs to sing
today would it what did those songs mean
and what did it mean to be there
well it was it was a first it was an
honor for us to be there and and to be
able to sing those songs were requested
um uh by I think some of the family
Elvis How Great Thou Art was one of the
the songs that that he'd done just about
every show and it was always something
that was very special and then also the
sweet sweet spirit is another one that
he he just loved and loved the harmonies
of it and like I said it was it was an
honor for us to be here and and to be a
part of this what did it mean to be able
to honor Lisa Marie
it was an honor and a privilege to be
invited to her memorial service
something I never thought we'd be
involved with but it was quite quite the
honor
wait I hear that low that low end tone
it was it was so beautiful
well it's it's on loan from God this
voice is so and I use it to sing glory
to him
[Music]
thank you